Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new superman man of steel 2 movie video
there was a recent interview with a bunch of
dc people and james gunn talking about other dc
movies where they revealed some surprising details
about what's going on with the next superman solo
movie behind the scenes so we'll break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we'll do an amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do with the
next superman solo movie but just starting with
the big stuff first number five recently warner
brothers in dc did a big preview of the suicide
squad movie that's coming out next year and during
that interview they revealed that the new regime
that's now in charge of all warner brothers in dc
movies really wants to make a new superman movie
despite what you may have heard they actually do
want to do something like that there were a lot
of rumors earlier this year about what was going
on with henry cavill and zack snyder after the
justice league snyder cut trailer was released and
they made all the announcements about the future
of that movie that's all still ongoing right now
he just posted a picture of them starting the
reshoots or additional photography whatever you
want to call what they're doing with the snyder
cut because now the movie is sort of ballooned
into a very injustice version of a justice league
movie i'll address that in a second after the man
of steel 2 movie stuff but one of the first things
that james gunn revealed in his interview was that
when he had his first general meeting with warner
brothers a couple years ago about working on a dc
movie the studio actually tried to get him to do a
superman movie first before he came back with his
own requests and obviously that wound up being the
suicide squad movie he also said some funny things
about kevin feige when he had to tell the marvel
people that he was doing a dc movie apparently
kevin feige is also a bit of a superman stan
he literally said the day after he got
hired to do the suicide squad movie
disney called him and hired him back or wanted
to hire him back to do guardians of the galaxy 3
so he had to call kevin foggy and explain the
situation to him and before he could explain
which dc movie he was doing kevin feige stopped
him short and said are you doing superman are
you doing a new superman movie please tell me not
because kevin feige was upset just because he was
so excited and thought that james good might
be doing a superman movie because kevin feige
actually got his start in hollywood working for
richard donner and his wife lauren shuladonner
so even though you don't hear him talk about
it a lot apparently he is a huge superman stand
but number four quick history lesson just to
explain the history of the man of steel 2 superman
movie james gunn and zack snyder's personal
histories at the studio because it's all connected
in fact james gunn and zack snyder go way back
they have history together if you didn't know
their total bros they actually worked on a movie
together a long time ago remember zack snyder's
dawn of the dead remake movie that was his first
real big movie that he did that was written by
james gunn so they've been friends in real life
for a long time now eventually zack snyder was
hired to do the superman man of steel movie with
henry cavill christopher nolan was kind of on his
way out of dc so dc wanted to work up to a big
shared universe of justice league characters
eventually they signed zack snyder on to do the
future justice league movies but originally what
he was going to do after the first superman movie
was he was going to do man of steel too but the
studio wanted to get to their justice league movie
so fast that they decided to turn man of steel 2
into batman v superman so had things gone to
their original plans he would have just done
man of steel 2 right after doing the first man
of steel movie this will be important in a second
but obviously you know what happened after that he
made batman v superman then they signed him on for
three justice league movies remember originally
they planned to do three of them as a trilogy then
you all know what happened after batman v superman
came out by that time zack snyder had already
started shooting with henry cavill ben affleck
the rest of the justice league actors on the movie
critics freaked out about batman v superman the
studio panicked and that was back in 2016 when
you started hearing about all the changes behind
the scenes on the set of the justice league movie
they dropped it down to two justice league movies
then eventually joss whedon came on and here we
are today cut to a couple years later and zack
snyder's coming back to finish his original
vision of the snyder cut although technically
it's actually morphing into a much bigger movie
but had things gone to their original plans after
they had done justice league 2 zack snyder would
have just come back and done man of steel 2 with
henry cavill eventually they were always going to
do another superman solo movie but they just had
all these justice league plans before that would
happen number three james gunn said that he was
pitched the man of steel 2 movie or a new superman
movie whatever you want to call it back in summer
of 2018 when he was first meeting with the warner
brothers people he'd been fired by disney and
marvel from the guardians of the galaxy 3 movie
they announced that during the summer of 2018
within about a month of that he was having general
meetings with warner brothers in dc about doing
a new dc movie it was during those early meetings
that james gunn said the studio started talking
to him about doing the new superman movie he said
that the reason why he said no to that and instead
chose to do the suicide squad movie is just
because he preferred working with characters like
the guardians of the galaxy characters basically
misfits dc-list characters so he basically wound
up doing a guardians of the galaxy style movie
with dc characters even though technically the
suicide squad movie doesn't take place in outer
space technically recently they've also talked
about the villain of the new suicide squad movie
most of us theorize that it's actually starro
a space-based character because if you re-watch
all that suicide squad trailer footage from dc
fandom you can actually see purple starro looking
prosthetics covering some of the cast faces but
the takeaway here is that clearly if the studio is
trying to get him to do a new superman movie it's
a priority for them and it seems like the real
reason why they haven't hired another director
and announced man of steel 2 is because they're
just waiting for the right one to come along
number two here's where we get to the recent
zack snyder rumors about his potential future with
dc projects beyond the justice league snyder cut
everyone wondering if zack snyder's going to do
more dc projects after the snyder cut next year
the past year or so he's really only been
talking about the snyder cut they're in the
middle of additional photography there's still a
ton of work to be done on that he's mostly just
focused on that right now it's going to be over
four hours long they're releasing it on hbo max
in four separate episodes sometime between next
spring and summer it's going to be huge based on
all the recent trailers announcements and plot
teasers from behind the scenes it does kind of
seem like it's almost turning into an injustice
movie just a little bit but the most recent
rumors are that warner brothers is actually just
waiting to see how the snyder cut performs and
what the fan critical reaction winds up being but
there's a strong possibility that they're using
the whole thing the whole endeavor to keep zack
snyder around at dc for potential future projects
the people that were running the studio when he
left the justice league movie a couple years ago
have all been fired and replaced with a totally
new regime so it's one of those situations where
they might be trying to bring him back if everyone
is digging what he's doing with the snyder cut
so even though i would have never expected this
a couple years ago we could totally wind up with
a situation where zack snyder himself comes back
to do man of steel 2 with henry cavill in a couple
more years and if you want a theory craft remember
what was happening a couple months ago when he
announced the justice league snyder cut it was
during a rewatch commentary stream of the man of
steel movie where he brought henry cavill superman
onto the stream to help announce the snyder cut
it's not a confirmation or anything but it
almost seems like too much of a coincidence
in number one just speaking about henry cavill
superman in other dc movies he's spoken more
recently in the last couple of months about
all the cameo rumors in shazam 2 the black
adam movie potential other future dc movies but
most of what he said is just standard boilerplate
because he's pretty official when it comes to
interviews yes i'm talking with the studio no
most of these rumors aren't totally correct
but he wouldn't elaborate on what he and the
dc people are actually talking about but you
go back and you watch the rock himself in that
dc fandom trailer for the black adam movie clearly
hyping up superman vs black adam in a future movie
if not the black adam movie itself so if
that's going to wind up happening then some
of the other rumors about the cameos and other
dc movies are also probably a little bit true
you know i always thought that it might be cool
to hang out with superman that would be cool
right i mean we're kind of similar in terms of
our powers our strengths our speeds because look
at the end of the day you never know black adam
and superman could become friends or they won't
who knows maybe we'll see but before i go i want
you guys to help me out with something let's let
flash shazam aquaman wonder woman batman and
superman let's let them know something things
will never be the same because the hierarchy
of power in the dc universe is about to change
the big takeaway though is that yes he's totally
coming back as superman in new movies eventually
it just seems like they're taking things
on a movie by movie basis and just seeing
how things perform before they fully commit
to a new superman movie but everyone post
all your theories in the comments below do you
actually want to see zack snyder come back to
do man of steel 2 himself in a couple years with
henry cavill what's going to happen next though
is i have a new thor 4 love and thunder video
to post tonight and then friday i'm going to
be posting my mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
that's right the mandalorian is back i'll be doing
weekly episode videos so make sure you enable
alerts so you don't miss any of those episodes
but while you wait for everything everyone
click here to re-watch the justice league
snyder cut trailer a billion more times and
click here for that brand new green lantern hbo
announcement video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!